the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so anyway I'm Chris Babel and
I said I I'm the media development
director at the office of digital
learning which is what the K through 12
video project is part of as well as MITx
and ocw and a bunch of other initiatives
on campus I also teach a documentary
video class a science documentary class
here at MIT that Elizabeth took a few
years ago and what I'm going to talk
about is storytelling and specifically
visual storytelling and how that can
relate or hopefully will relate to the
work you do in this class and to online
video in general and I'm going to start
out just by taking maybe I don't know if
it's exception but just having a
slightly different perspective than
something that Elizabeth said I i would
say that almost all videos that are
successful also viral videos have some
element of a story to them even a
five-second vine video just about
everything and I actually was thinking
about that and I went looking for what
is probably one of the dumbest viral
videos to come out recently just for a
few days ago may have seen it this sum
is a fan at Ohio State who was caught on
the jumbotron basically scratching her
boyfriends head and then picking her
nose and this thing got I just it's
ridiculous how much play this got in
about a 12 hour 20 hour period very
ephemeral you know it's like absolutely
not going to last it's not going to
change anyone's life but the reason it
took off is that it has a story and the
story was created and invented by the
people who watched it it you know it's
not really go ahead above the point of
that
same thing I that she was with that's
like the guy should see you know exact
but it's actually not true and that was
the story that was completely created by
people who watched it they've been
together for a long time and she didn't
even know she was on the jumbotron
actually apparently but it just happens
to be this kind of you know like little
moment that tells a story and because it
told a story that people related to
suddenly turned into a giant thing well
I had one thing that's hilarious is
somebody actually reversed it so she
picks her nose and sort of leaves a
deposit on his neck and that we can
became another story for something
disturbing in better visuals yeah
exactly she looks guilty she looks
guilty and that's why that's part of the
story like oh my god you know like I've
been caught you know rubbing his neck so
anyway I think this is like gotta be the
dumbest you know viral video of all time
but I think it's also a story never
think you're not telling a story if you
forget everything else that I say in the
next 30-40 minutes I would remember this
there's some element of a story in what
you do I don't care if you're making a
an fda approval video as one of you
mentioned you are interested in doing
something i have actually done
personally i don't care if you're making
a 30-second TV commercial a 10-second TV
commercial a 12 minute physics
demonstration there is an element of
story to it and it may not be the sort
of conventional traditional television
story that we would see on an HBO show
it may not be a Hollywood movie story
but there is an element of story and one
of the things that you want to do here
is find what those elements are now you
know let's let's unpack that a little
bit let's talk about what is the story
and how might it relate to what you're
actually going to be doing here and then
secondly we also talked about what are
some of the specific techniques of
visual storytelling that you might be
able to employ so first of all what is
this story well I you know full
confession I went to film school and I
worked in that sort of ancient medium
that that Elizabeth talked to television
and film and the classic and traditional
way of talking about a story is that
it's got these
it's got a protagonist you know hero
it's got an inciting incident it's got
something that happens that sets
everything in motion then there are
barriers along the way problems that the
protagonist has overcome and then
there's a resolution so that is you know
you do that in a kind of traditional
classic way and you end up with
connections or worse right it's not
going to work obviously in the genre
that you're talking about another way of
looking at this traditional way is that
you know you've got after one which is
the setup you've got act to the barriers
the plot you got act three the
resolution and the you know the three
act structure is is kind of the classic
kind of screen writer mode that that you
see over and over again so how does that
relate to what we're actually doing well
this is going to be somewhat repetitive
to some of the things with Elizabeth
talked about first thing clearly that
you need to do in this very short form
is engage your audience immediately I
mean you've got maybe like you know 56
seconds maybe you know maybe eight or
ten to engage them on some level that's
the beginning of your story that's the
inciting incident uh and then this is
something that I find very interesting
and you know when I talk about web video
this is something that it's a paradox
that I think is really really true you
want to surprise your audience while
also showing them exactly what they want
to see and this is really this is can be
really a challenge surprise your
audience in other words you know you
want to take them somewhere show them
something that's fresh that's new that
they haven't seen before something
Elizabeth just mentioned but at the same
time you really want to you know you
need to sort of feed into their
expectations because otherwise they're
going to shut down and that is why you
know a lot of this sort of the the
YouTube channels and lot of the people
who do this work for a living I have a
genre that they stick to you know
smartereveryday ASAP all of you know
Vsauce you know hey I always jump up
from beneath the frame that's my thing
you know so you're showing people what
they want at the same time you're
surprising them and taking them
somewhere they've never been and it's
kind of a kind of a paradox but i think
it's it's kind of a
keep paradox and then the last thing is
leave your audience wanting more
shortness brevity is a very important
thing you know particularly for for this
I mean this is a series science out loud
you know the nicest thing for Elizabeth
would be if somebody said oh my god that
was so great click next one now if you
think about it this is very similar to a
three-act structure it's just a really
compressed three-act structure engage
your audience the inciting incident
surprise our audience and also showing
them what they want to see this is the
sort of the development which might only
take 30 seconds and then leave your
audience wanting more some kind of
resolution that that takes them to the
next thing the other the other element
of all of this that's very important to
just briefly mention in Elizabeth
mentioned this earlier is that in online
video just as we saw the Ohio State clip
a lot of the storytelling happens
outside the frame of your video and you
know you want to basically be able to
leverage that so people's expectations
before they see your video play into how
they you know perceive your story
they're experienced during and then what
they do after all of those are part of
the story as well so you know the naked
celebrity picture well that's kind of a
story too because you know you have an
experience of you know Brad Pitt in one
context and then suddenly wow is that
his but that's the story not a very good
one necessarily but i also want to talk
a little bit about protagonists you know
i started out talking about one of the
things you need is a protagonist well on
one level the protagonist is you if you
are the host of this video and we you
know if you think about the sort of
videos of elizabeth showed all of them
pretty much on one level or another have
a protagonist it's a very strong
character a very strong protagonist
whether it's crazy Russian science guy
or the smarter every day sort of you
know down-home but super smart Science
Guy or Vsauce you know with it love him
or hate him he's a very strong character
so heavy protagonist is
really really really important and that
protagonist is going to be you in this
particular instance but there's also
another protagonist that we should talk
about and that's your audience because
what you're doing is taking people on a
journey through this learning and some
of the barriers that are going to be
thrown up our barriers to their
understand it you know think about think
about smarter every day and that the cat
clip the whole thing is structured
around oh hey we now we know it's the
tail but no it's not no it's not it's
something else and that happens two or
three times over the course of the clip
that is basically a story that
storytelling there's a barrier to
understanding oh we think we've solved
it no we haven't you know it's like a
car chase it's like you know breaking in
to a safe it's like a lot of things that
that you would see in don't you know
conventional movie so there are actually
kind of in some ways you can think of it
as a dual protagonist you the trusted
guide are taking your buddy the audience
on this journey on a story to return to
what I would sit I said earlier I think
of web videos at you know great web
videos are like great snack food you you
know you there they're very familiar yet
they're also sort of spicy and enticing
and after you have one you just want to
have another you just and you have the
second one you just think maybe I should
have a third I don't know if you know
hopefully the videos you make won't
leave people with you know heartburn
which is what happens when you too many
of these but but that is to me kind of
an interesting analogy and if
interstellar or some three-hour opus
that you sit pay ten dollars to sit in
the dark to watch is a seven-course meal
at a four-star restaurant you're making
something that's just got to be really
tasty and delightful for just a moment
and leave people wanting another one
just exactly like that but you know
somehow subtly different too all right
i'm not going to show any video because
you going to try to just talk about the
videos you've already seen rather than
show
alright so let's unpack story is just a
little bit more um you know I've made
the case that you're telling a story and
you should never forget that you're that
you're telling a story when you do this
kind of work well what our story is
actually built on there's a whole list
of things and elizabeth is mentioned a
couple of them emotion now I mean I'm
not necessarily talking about gone with
the wind emotion but certainly curiosity
identification humor which is an emotion
all of those things really are going to
play into what you do and are very very
important character we've talked about
character conflict again not necessarily
you know high drama but but there's
often some kind of conflict and the
conflict may be up you thought the cat
was using its tail to spin that's not
the case but but some kind of conflict
barriers to to understanding I think are
very very important spectacle you know
again you're not going to do
interstellar you're not going to spend
you know 100 million dollars on CGI
you're not going to do the hobbit but
but often take you know that it's
another word for taking people a place
they've never been you know maybe you
can get into the nuclear reactor here
intellectual engagement I think that's
kind of the obvious one the easy one
that we can that we can all you know
think about when we're talking about
educational videos and in and of itself
I don't think it's enough but it
certainly it's certainly an important
one and you know there are plenty of
videos out there plenty of lecture
videos that basically just depend on
that and then the last two are two of my
favorite ones the unfamiliar becoming
familiar which is kind of the classic
science video but the familiar becoming
unfamiliar as well in other words you
think you know farts but you don't you
know despite all you know about farts in
one context you don't know that much and
here's why so I think
both of those are really interesting
structures for you to use to hang a
story on you know the again the first
one obviously you know I'm going to take
this thing that you don't understand and
I'm going to make it completely you know
I'm going to demystify it but you know a
lot of science or science education is
also about kind of taking something that
seems really simple and showing just how
complex and intriguing and unfamiliar it
really is all right now let's talk a
little bit about visual storytelling
because that's obviously what you want
to do here lecture videos again
intellectual engagement certainly one
way to go if you use oh c WS a couple
you've mentioned you know you know very
well that lecture videos can be
effective and in fact lectures can be
great stories I me know we all have had
experiences of people who tell who are
great lecturers who tell great stories
and those stories may or may not be
visual but I think there are certain
things that distinguished visual
storytelling there are worth talking
about and this is a concept that i often
use to just kind of get into to this
whole idea which Elizabeth will probably
remember and this is what what we
sometimes call the plastic elements of
video or a film and sometimes I use film
and video indistinguishably because you
know betrays my age you know video is
film film is video now at this point
what I mean by the plastic elements of a
video are just simply all of the things
that we have control over when we make a
video and that could be the casting of
the actors it could be where we put the
camera that's kind of the obvious one
the lighting there's an endless list of
things and in fact here just a few of
them again you know most people would
list the camera right away since that's
kind of you know the paintbrush
quote-unquote the lighting how we choose
to light something or whether we're
actually using literally using lights
you're just using this
or existing room lights editing sound
music characters the actors locations
props costumes the list is really
endless it's really it goes back to the
decisions you know Elizabeth mentioned
decision-making all of these things are
things you need to think about and you
can control and they can work for you or
they can work against you you know think
about in smarter every day props the cat
itself of course is a great prop think
about the stuffed cat at the beginning
which is that sort of fun moment of oh
my God he's really going to drop a real
cat so he you know that was a choice
that was a choice to to add that stuffed
cat and it sort of made a fun little
moment that brought you in for just a
second location is very very important I
mean you know the sort of lowest common
denominator location is a chalkboard or
a whiteboard for something like you know
for an educational video but there are
all sorts of other possibilities
costumes again doesn't have to be you
know clown costumes or silly hats or
things like that although it could be
but all of the other things that you can
or might be able to bring to your video
by making these choices camera of course
is is is is a crucial one and I'm going
to unpack that just a little bit as well
although we could spend of course hours
talking about about film grammar so I'm
going to just go through a few other
tips to think about the first one and
this is kind of like you know the the
Bible of visual storytelling show don't
tell and it sounds kind of obvious but
it isn't necessarily that easy to do if
you if we think about the sleep video I
think one of the things that that I
responded to in that video that I
thought could have been better is that
it's actually not showing us much it's
telling us the the you know Elizabeth
talked about the this third of the fact
that the voice-over just read like a web
article like that sort of you know 10
facts about
and that's basically the case I mean
there are some really cool animation and
the animation is fun and it helps and it
definitely supports the words but
together it's really just you know this
thing you know I could have listened to
it on my ipod I could have listened to
it in my car the video the visuals
helped a little bit but it didn't really
add anything to it the the you know the
other way to do it of course is smarter
every day which you know you know again
you may or may not have like that you
may have thought that it would drag on
too long and I agree with that certainly
I think there were things that could
have been improved but there's nothing
like dropping a cat and showing it in
super slow motion to you know get my
attention so I think I think that was a
great example of showing something so
this is just something I wanted to
mention having worked on you know in
television there was a just a saying
that that went around a lot when people
were talking about a script which was oh
this is kind of a wolf pack deal and
what was meant by that this was sort of
an infamous situation from I don't know
God knows when somebody who's scripting
a nature documentary had written this
you know lon probably you know very
beautiful kind of flowery narration
about you know the the ravenous pack
loped across the frozen tundra in search
of its prey blah blah blah you know like
two pages of sort of beautiful prose and
you know at some point in in you know in
the editing process somebody was like
because they had you know that they
didn't need to say all of that stuff all
they had they had you know the picture
was worth endless amounts of stuff so
you know avoid your wolf pack moments if
you don't need to say something you can
show it there may be plenty of things to
say and I'm not saying that you know it
should be all visual but but you don't
need to say certain things if you're
already showing those things
use your language use your words which
are very important to do other things to
reinforce to bring your own perspective
to to embellish the story to you know
bring people into your own mind your own
character you don't need to say the
obvious stuff you don't need to you know
do the Wolfpack description so that's
sure don't tell the other thing that's
just a sort of a fundamental tip is
video loves motion moving pictures
people you know and and Joshua is going
to talk about storyboarding and
animation later in the week clearly
animated pictures moving things things
that reveal one thing or another in
animation are it's really important same
with cameras you know if you look at
science out loud some of the other
episodes you'll see some really terrific
moves with a camera dollies all of those
things add add visual interest and
improve your storytelling locking down a
tripod can also be very effective but
again think of it as a plastic element
that you can control don't do it just
because you didn't think about it do it
after thinking about what you're doing
by either moving or not moving so why so
the camera loves motion this is this is
kind of the corollary to that and I
don't know if if people have a lot of
shooting experience or not and this
isn't really strictly a class on you
know the technique production techniques
but this is something I really wanted to
mention motion for the sake of motion is
also not terrific not fantastic hosing
down the room is that sort of tendency
that your uncle or your grandfather has
when you give them a camera to just do
this all the time and you're growing
like oh hey I'm getting everything I'm
just getting everything here this is
fantastic and in fact what you get is
absolutely nothing because there's app
there's no intentionality there's no
sort of thought to what's happening with
the camera all you're doing is making
everybody sick and really pissed that
you're not focusing on anything
motion is actually I think a better way
to talk about it in story terms is
reveals when you're moving things you're
revealing the next story element so if I
pan from our camera person over to Josh
and josh is looking over here at the
camera person is going like why is he
doing what he's doing that's a story
element whereas if I do this I'm not
telling a story at all same with
animation and I'm sure josh thinks about
this night and day I mean how do you
reveal your next thing from the thing
you've got how you go from this idea to
that idea how do you reveal using motion
because it is moving pictures so um so
that's maybe a more pointed way of
talking about about motion in a story in
story terms revealing things I'm going
to talk a little just a little tiny bit
about grammar and framing and and stuff
like that very quickly this is a just as
still from an interview that I did a
couple of years ago here at MIT Joel
Dawson professor mihir and just a couple
of things to just point out about it in
terms of sort of visual just the way
visually it's set up first of all you'll
see that that the background and the
foreground are very distinct we shot it
so that the background is completely out
of focus and that's so that you know
what to focus on you that's the other
thing so we talked about reveal the
other the other sort of key crucial
thing to think about when you're
storyboarding or creating animation or
directing is how do you get people to
look at what you want them to look at in
the frame one way is to foreground the
foreground and let the background drop
off either through lighting or through
the focus in this case or through art
direction there are all sorts of ways to
do it but but doing it is really
important
the other thing is that this is a
close-up sounds kind of simple sounds
kind of obvious but it's making a choice
to go in and to find out about this guy
this person it's not about the lab it's
not just sort of this wishy washy moving
shot of him sort of wandering around his
lab doing something we want to hear what
this person is saying what he's thinking
right now just another quick thing to
just talk about when you're shooting in
this particular format 1660 by nine
there are a couple of really powerful
parts of the frame that you can use
whether you're doing animation or
shooting and they tend to be that where
the Third's cross each other so that's a
very powerful part of the frame that's
also powerful these are powerful in
slightly different ways and you'll see
as I is like dead dead on in the
crosshairs if we're people who you know
are read left to right well you know who
in sort of you know the euro European
tradition of writing this tends to be
the most powerful point because we read
frames left to right because we're used
to our eyes used to going that way not
saying you'd have to follow this rule
you can break it but it's just an
interesting thing for you to know that
when you're framing things when you're
creating animations you know there's a
tendency when you start to think oh dead
center would be really great but it's
actually not the case a little off
center and in in the sort of the thirds
of the frame is is a good way to go the
other thing just to talk about quickly
in terms of making choices think about
when and this will this will really come
up when you work do your storyboarding
exercises with Josh think about what
what the kinds of shots you you choose
are doing wide shots say one thing
close-ups say another starting with a
wide shot and coming in that's a reveal
of something but coming starting in a
close up and going wide can also be a
reveal of something else and you know we
can boat
we can imagine what kinds of stories
might come out of these two frames and
how the story might be different if we
started here and went in here and if we
started here and came out so make
choices and think about what your
choices are actually going to do in
terms of the story another example of
that camera angles framing low angles
looking up that gives you a certain
feeling it gives you a certain kind of
power so you know sort of you know
master of my domain feel the opposite
looking down kind of the opposite this
these are is two examples and I'm not
going to go on and on and on and talk
about about others although we may get
into it later in the week but the point
the point is is that the camera is kind
of one of the key plastic elements that
you have at your disposal to tell your
story and the medium shot just kind of
center frame you know doing your thing
is kind of the fall back you don't have
to do that there are any number of other
choices you can make and when you start
to go and choose locations and choose
props and choose elements like that how
you shoot those things and how you shoot
your characters becomes very very very
important and then the last thing that
I'm going to talk about and I'm kind of
racing through this because I want to
just make sure we have time for
questions and stuff I'm just going to be
a little counterintuitive we've been
talking about visual storytelling but
just don't don't short change your sound
sound is often more important than the
picture and one of the other things that
I think you know we talked to Elizabeth
talked a little bit about about
production technique and sort of you
know cortical bad technique or rough
videos vs vs slicker kind of TV style
videos one thing that's very very very
hard to overcome his poor sound and even
if your videos a little out of focus and
it's shaky if it's really compelling
that's fine as long as the sound is good
but as soon as the sound is bad and hard
to listen to you're going to have a
really hard time pulling people back so
you know we even though this is mostly
about visual storytelling I just want to
point that out that that doesn't mean
that the sound is not important in fact
the sound is extraordinarily important
and it's a you know both the technical
thing but also a plastic element that
you can use whether it's music or sound
effects or the way you treat dialogue
all of those things are are really
important so anyway so just to
contextualize this a little bit I know
that Elizabeth co-instructor George is
going to be doing a workshop a scripting
workshop with you and he's going to be
focusing a lot on finding your voice
which is really really important and
goes back to the idea of character and
you know the protagonist and
authenticity and all a lot of the things
Elizabeth was talking about but as you
do that as you do all of those things
remember that ultimately you're telling
a visual story and that you once you
sort of hone your your story hone your
voice you want to put that in a visual
context you don't have to have the words
carry everything and in fact the words
may end up doing other things than
conveying kind of the core of what you
need to do so that's it I kind of tried
to race through it because they didn't
want to keep people for too long but
first of all any any questions or
thoughts
I just had a thought 18 hours a question
interesting you mentioned that the
sorry the names escaping me the white
work together
seeking earlier oh the ASAP science yeah
and I mean I liked it I didn't mean to
need a dump on it but we're a really
interesting point and I so then I was
saying okay what would have been more
effective you know how could that have
been turned into some sort of more
storytelling exercise or
and I you know I think would be an
interesting question you know just how
could that be made better and my my
feeling was would it be better to do
something where you actually had someone
not sleeper overnight for two days well
I think that's yeah yeah no go no go
ahead yeah you know something like
supersize me yeah where you have someone
actually engages and it's more
experiential as opposed to being
effective I guess would be the
distinction there well I think that's
really good point I think I mean that's
kind of the smarter everyday approach
which I respond to personally better on
the other hand I mean I think that there
are graphics that tell amazing stories I
mean I think you know data
visualizations that I've seen recently
in particular or just can be an
extraordinary story telling sort of you
know devices and so so it's not so much
that I think that it was animated and
somehow that was you know not as
effective it's that I think the process
was right script and then come up with
sort of stuff to fill in space so so
yeah I personally respond more to the
ones that are more experiential where
you have you have people you know that
may also be supported by animation but
there is kind of a there's someone
taking you through the experience but I
do think that that there are lots and
lots of ways to tell really really
dynamic and really interesting good
stories with animation so
oh no totally I mean I and you know I
mean I mean I we've all been there I've
been there too I mean you have something
that you have to make come alive and I
think they did a great job of making it
come alive i think the animation is it
was really effective it's just that i
think it the approach was to write to
write a script without necessarily
thinking about the visual medium and
then to take the visuals and layer them
on top as a separate part of the process
so so anybody else have any means i cut
again i know i kind of race through it
how many people i mean do you have video
experience how many people have some
kind of video experience it's always a
really good question to ask no nobody
well that's cool that's great um yeah
yeah absolutely no absolutely absolutely
I think you know just to just to go back
a little bit I mean I think that whole
relationship between web video and TV is
a really interesting one it's a really
interesting one to unpack because again
the sort of conventional storytelling
techniques that that we're used to
seeing on TV are not going to be
effective for all sorts of reasons you
know it's also worth mentioning that of
course TV has changed to radically since
connections I mean you know Game of
Thrones doesn't open that way yeah two
minutes of sort of somebody wandering
around a house but but at the same time
it is a different it is a different
genre and a really a crucial thing is
kind of the thing that Elizabeth alluded
to and I mentioned at the beginning that
I think you're telling a story but your
story extends beyond the bounds of your
video or can extend beyond the bounds of
your video it it basically can begin
with what people's preconceptions are
before they start watching and it
continues on after the vid
is done and I think that is a really
crucial difference one one suggestion
that I would make you know whenever you
write something this weekend you know
you're going to be writing treatments
and pitches and scripts think about it
in purely visual terms I mean one of the
you know one of the early exercises that
I had to do when I was in grad school
were silent films and films that you
know or versions of scripts that had no
dialogue had no sound at all and I think
that's I'm not saying that you should do
that as of as a as a technique in your
finished piece but it's a way of
bringing up stuff that you can then
apply to your video later so you know if
you were going to do something that was
purely visual that was going to convey
what you wanted to convey how would you
do it and what might you sort of create
or invent or think about through that
process that you can then use to inform
your script so just a just a way of
thinking about what you're what you're
going to be doing this week
you